energy is a word we hear all the time in
seemingly different contexts almost
every single day
we hear about renewable energy on the
news and particularly in the winter we
hear people talking about their energy
bills because
they're worried about how much it's
going to cost to heat their homes so
this brings about the question of what
is energy
that we can talk about it so often and
in seemingly such different ways
so in physics we actually have a
specific definition of what energy is
and you'll see it's really not that
different from how we talk about energy
day to day
energy and physics is defined as the
ability to do work
we can't talk about energy without
talking about work so
we should probably define that right now
because work is another one of these
words that we use an awful lot
but once again physics has a specific
definition for it
in physics work is performed when you
apply force over a distance
we can actually write this as an
equation w equals f
times d where w is work f is force and d
is distance or displacement if you've
ever moved a box a suitcase or really
any object in your room
across the floor just to get out of your
way you performed work
you had to apply force to that box to
move it whatever distance it took to get
out of your way
if it was a short distance you can see
from the equation that that's going to
be
less work than if you have to move it
across your entire room down the hall
into another room
and in order to perform this work to
move the box out of your way you had to
have energy available
that energy is enabling you to do the
work because you're going to transfer
the energy from yourself
to that box in order to move it so
another way that we can think about work
and
energy is that the change in energy of
the system
in this case you in the box is actually
equal to the work done
when we define energy this way it allows
us to do a lot of interesting things
we've set up a way to measure and
calculate energy so it's actually a
quantifiable property
let's go back to the example of a box
and let's say that
instead of just trying to move a box out
of your way in your room
you're actually going to pack up
everything in your room because you're
going to move to a completely different
house
and now you have 10 boxes to move we can
actually calculate the energy required
to move all of those boxes you might be
saying to yourself
wait a minute i'm now moving 10 boxes
that actually sounds kind of tiring
and if i'm getting tired does that mean
i'm actually losing energy
it turns out that energy is coming from
somewhere and in this case it's going to
come from
food so as you're moving these boxes you
may find yourself getting hungry
so you should probably grab a snack
something like i don't know
an apple let's pretend that's what i've
drawn there
so that you can get more energy to move
the rest of those 10 boxes
and you might be thinking now wait a
minute
this energy coming from food to me seems
different
than energy between me and moving a box
and that's because you can actually see
the box moving
which brings us to our next point energy
comes in various forms and they don't
all look the same
we have equations to quantify the energy
of these various forms and we'll talk
about those
in another video but the key here is
that
energy can transfer between objects and
it can also convert between different
forms
such as when you eat and get energy from
the apple
and then you use that energy to move a
box
so to summarize energy is the ability to
do work
work is done when you apply force across
the distance and we can write that as an
equation
and because we can calculate the energy
of a system using equations
we now know that energy is a
quantifiable property